the producer and dj uh and this man
is uh also the con the co-owner of fan
control football and he wants to talk
about
something called the fan control
football ballers collective nft
joining us here on the rich eisen show
the two-time grammy award nominee
uh on the mercedes-benz van phone line
steve aoki how are you steve
hey what's up guys dude how are you
doing where are you where have i where
have you come in uh from are you in
vegas right now are you in l.a where are
we calling yeah i know i'm in vegas i
live out in vegas okay i'm out here you
were you were you were at the first uh
game this year for the raiders right you
were you were the dj of the moment there
for raiders versus ravens right yeah
yeah yeah i was there for the raiders
game yeah that was uh
that was a great start to uh the season
for them you know okay um and i mean
it's just that stadium is is insane this
beautiful stadium so just to get people
in there just the vibe in there is great
i've seen a couple games in there
already yeah um awesome stadium uh and
is that the largest room you've ever
dj'd for steve
i imagine yeah i mean it's definitely up
there you know for sure what do you mean
up there there's been you've you've dj'd
for bigger places than than uh than the
current home of the las vegas raiders
that's impressive
i mean like like you know and and many
of the times i don't really play in in a
room like that or like in and that's not
really indoors but uh fields when you do
like a field of people it could be a lot
but a lot of people you know
all right that's very good i've got my
we have right here on the rich eisen
show steve i'm going to bring him right
in here he's our audio executive as he
likes to be known he dj's himself would
you say on the side right now on the
side i started in 79 okay steve he's a
little bit jealous he's a little bit
jealous he wanted me to ask because we
we have contacts on the host of nfl
network i have contacts with the nfl he
wanted to be the one to be the first dj
no i just want to do it in the end zone
no no mike you could admit that's where
he did it from i know no he's so did you
do it from the club steve
where were you like a bob you were above
the club right
you were in your own um
where uh where was i i was like where
you know they have the bands performed
yeah like they have like the live music
perform up on top right by the uh
it's like a digital flame yeah the flame
yeah yeah so it's like right up there so
it's not down on the floor
although i i i did see i was at a game
and i saw a marshmallow played at
halftime and he was down there yeah
so how many people do you have in your
life steve aoki who came up come up to
you and say they're a dj
um and think that they could do what you
do how many people in your life do you
have come up to you like um steve i mean
there's definitely uh um
the young the young guys and girls that
that are coming up with
with you know um aspirational dreams and
questions and
and uh of course so you know if i have
time i'll sit down and talk to him
but yeah i mean it's it's a it's like
obviously it's a lot of fun
um you know what you see in pictures and
videos but it's a lot of work well how
many no you have to really really get
get in there and
put in the time in the studio and on
your sets et cetera how many people are
pushing or divorced men pushing 60 come
up to you and say that they could do it
how many how many of those people four
of them because it's a very very uh
small
minority people
hey you know what there's a demographic
for everybody you know what i mean so
especially first on siriusxm you have
you fill every demo on siriusxm so the
perfect place to start okay see mike do
you want your own show then cause steve
might be able to hook you up what do you
think all right
he like used streams from his house on a
friday night you know what i'm a mix
cloud i think he's steve that's what
we're doing okay quick and mixed clouds
steve we all do it i don't even know i
don't yeah i'm not a mixed club
[Laughter]
mike i'm giving you i'm giving you a
spot to talk to an elite
and elite
i could open for steve i'd have fun
maybe a little denmark collection here
between dell twofold
steve my house steve you're looking for
an opener you're looking for an opener
steve
hey you know what you know i i don't
discriminate you know especially on the
age i think it's like it's important to
get the uh the older folks in yeah it's
not just about the young heads yeah so
you know let's get them all in steve let
me let me help you out here um even
though we've just met you should
discriminate right now
you should be very discriminatory right
now but to be very honest with you i'm
trying to i'm trying to help out uh
somebody who's called into the show all
right uh so let's talk about uh fan
controlled football and you've got this
this is something else the team owners
for those who may not know austin eckler
marshawn lynch dalvin cook you got the
barber brothers and richard sherman how
do you get all these guys together and
tell them let's uh let's go into
business together steve i think i think
what the point is is that the the world
is changing and it's innovating at a
rapid pace
and a rapid pace
and
now you have
ways in which fans which i think
that like just the concept alone the
concept alone that a fan
who's you know fans die hard they're
like following the game they're doing
their fantasy football teams they they
follow each team they follow each player
imagine if you could actually
participate in a team
i mean just that
as a as a philosophy
is something that you know i think
something that we all wanted i mean
people that that love sports would love
to to participate
not just as a fan but to participate in
and you know and the revenue and growing
and and the the creative behind it so uh
when i heard that i was all in
i mean like i think that these kinds of
concepts they're going to start brewing
in every industry
you know and and it makes sense that
it's happening in sports it's seven on
six so it's seven on seven on half a
football field about 50 yard field one
hour running clock no kicking or special
teams
and and
what happens for those who may not be
familiar with it steve
yeah so there's different teams right
right uh there's different teams that
are that are playing on the field and um
i own one team
okay um cuevo from the migos owns
another marshawn lynch has another
and uh fans come in and they can
participate in each in in whatever team
they want whatever team they they feel
like that they want to uh
put their time and investment in
and um
and we start building the team we start
we we design the jerseys together we we
uh you know you can make plays you can
make plays on what you think will happen
with your players how they're going to
play you know
they're going to play the ball and if if
what you predict happens
you your your prediction not only
does you win on whatever sort of bet you
make but
uh you you get on a leaderboard and you
get
you you get value for that you get no
like you get noticed from that and that
that's uh kept up on a leaderboard which
i think is really important like imagine
if you always make the plays
and
you're just 90
you know all on the button you always
get it at least like you it gets
everyone can see it
and i think that's really important to
see like you want to see that you want
to kind of
flex with your friends like look at me i
made all the plays i know all the stuff
right i mean we love doing that who who
does it right so
i think there's a lot of different
points of interest for people to jump in
and
get involved because it's just a lot of
fun you it's like just adding a little
bit more sweat to what you're doing and
make you know adding a little more salt
to the popcorn so that when you when you
do like
watch the game you're just so much more
invested than just having a fantasy
football league yes played in a single
high-tech studio arena it's like madden
for real life uh fcf and then what's the
fcf ballers collective
steve what's that about fcm that's yet
ballers collective is basically just
it's exactly what i'm talking about you
know it's like it's a the collective of
different teams coming together and and
making this happen and and this is early
we're early right now so this is you
know we just had one season and i just
developed this team for this new season
and uh
and we're gonna continue to grow it and
just like with anything
you know the people will will
will
show you that it will be a success or
not yeah right and then there's an nft
involved in this now as well i guess
that's what i meant is what's the nft
part of this oh right yeah so like just
like i mean i'm i'm big on nfts
i've been heavy into the space for quite
some time
and um we're incorporating you know nft
component with our team okay so um i'm
sure other teams are going to be doing
the same thing but uh my coat my partner
on our team is also heavy into the nfc
space so of course we're going into it
um with another utility so people can
get involved
and you know
uh build up a secondary market and you
know build actual another revenue stream
on the nft game so it's
um there's a lot more that we're going
to announce as we develop it further
very good steve aoki so everybody could
check out uh more where where can people
go to check out more of what you're
you're talking about for um i mean what
so i'm i'm like just involved in all
different kinds of industries
uh
but with fcf just look that up on google
i'm sure you can just figure it out and
find it out for yourself uh for me it's
everything is pretty much steve aoki so
if you go to my website steve aoki dot
com or twitter or instagram
all that stuff is there when it comes to
nfts
pretty much twitter is the the the like
the place where people communicate on
nfcs it's not instagram it's not tick
tock it's really like twitter okay so
um even though it seems to be a dated
mark uh social media platform
um
it's it's still it's still really uh the
most responsive when it comes to this i
mean yeah i guess it's dated because if
i'm on it it must be dated
so
i mean
that's the way we communicate mostly
you've got 8.2 million followers on
there not too bad for being dated steve
i'll tell you that um so
all right uh is it true that when you
threw out a ceremonial first pitch at
dodger stadium you actually threw a
cupcake first is that an actual fact
steve yeah yeah you know and it was uh
the dodgers gave me the cupcake so they
they came prepared they're like okay we
want you to do you
right i'm like all right you know i mean
obviously this thing like broke apart in
the air you know
but uh but i remember the uh the catcher
he was a good sport and he like
picked up the pieces that were on the
ground and like put it in his own face
really okay and so you're a lefty huh
you come from the left side
i got it yeah yeah okay i got a good
curveball you got a southpaw you got a
southpaw situation all right so you're
in vegas right now and you're just
living your life and uh again uh mike
deltufo is his name dj mikey d as in
dee's nuts right isn't that what uh
isn't that what snoop snoop gave you
your drop uh do you have that you want
to play that for steve aoki because
again i don't know if you've got a snoop
drop steve but so does that do it's your
boy big snoop do double g coming at you
live from los angeles and my dj dj mikey
d
d is in these news what do you think of
that steve what do you think of that
that i mean you have definitely
that's leveled up i don't i don't know
many many people with a snoop dogg drop
that's pretty big deal okay
all right i don't know what the what i
don't know what uh the term is of
footsteps that you might hear in your
business but uh those are those belong
to dj monkey d so be on the lookout
these nuts i like i got another drop now
oh no
i can't see you thanks man
steve thanks for calling in really
appreciate it absolutely let's do it
again all right guys all right there you
go thank you at steve aoki be part of
the gajillions to follow him love it
there you go
[Laughter]
you wanted his spot
no i want to open for guys like him i
can't play with that those guys are
superstars
you're a superstar no no no no no i'm
gonna give me just an opening for one of
those guys so you wanted to play the
raider game that's richard no i would be
i would be a great hype dj for football
games so it's only because that's what
that's what i do
is steve aoki right now after hanging up
the phone shaking his head like you did
about the mention of jeff walker
you know not at all like he's shaking
his head like oh god not that person
who said and then a week later he'd be
like well i just didn't know who he was
yeah they said yeah yeah
something yeah and just saying whatever
is that what he's doing right now
i got another drop though we gotta get
that i gotta go oh yeah yeah there you
go
he was very impressed with your snoop
dogg job that's a great job hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here